hi there steve kaufman here again today
i'm going to talk about learning
vocabulary now i did say in my previous
video that
i would be uh amenable to doing some
videos in different languages we've had
some requests
so uh but today i'm going to speak in
english but i'm going to aim for the
next one maybe in portuguese because
that was the largest number of requests
followed by japanese french i think
there was some italian and uh
spanish
mandarin so we'll try and sneak all of
those in but i won't do them one after
another i'll intersperse it with
english videos because most people only
understand
english
um now vocabulary we have a very
interesting
thread going over at our one of our
forums at link uh someone started a
thread on how many words can you learn
in a day
and i'm going to post a link to this
thread in my on my blog
the linguist language which i leave a
link to here in the explanations or
information box underneath the video
so how many words can you learn in a day
we've seen a number of sort of extreme
positions i tend to take the extreme
position that you can learn a lot of
words
hundreds in a day a hundred anyway
one person on our forum thinks the
number is
one three five depending on the language
so let's first of all define our terms
what do we mean by learning a word
well to me learning a word means being
able to recognize a word in a specific
context in a context when you are
reading or listening my focus is on
comprehension
some people feel that you only know a
word when you can actually use it and
produce it
so that's point number one and i'll get
back to that the second thing is
what do we mean by a word
at link at our website at our learning
community
we count every form of the word as a
different word and we do this for a
specific reason because
in those languages like russian or
slavic languages which have a lot of
declensions or korean which has a lot of
different endings to words
i find it useful to
treat each word as a different
phenomenon see how it performs in a
phrase or sentence try to understand how
that word functions depending on its
form
so but i mean it doesn't matter i think
if we if you only want to count word
families
uh it becomes a little more difficult to
define you know in in english for
example is uh i don't know active
activity
reactive act are they the same word
different words it's a little difficult
to define however i know that um
paul nation
who is a leading expert on english
vocabulary acquisition feels that the
ratio between words and word families or
rather word families to words is one to
1.6 in english it's probably 1.3 in some
languages maybe in russian it's 1.5 i
don't know i don't know the way i count
them every form of a word is a different
word
and of course i if i can recognize a
word i consider that word known
a lot of people don't like that
um it also depends on how similar the
new language is to a language you
already know for example in romanian i
went in there and seventy percent of the
vocabulary is at least recognizable
based on my knowledge of romance
languages
so i mean my numbers for
romanian in two months
my link statistics tell me that i know
over 20 000 words
and that i have also saved in other
words linked on our site another 10 000
words in this two month period now many
of the links that i created were phrases
and of course i don't know all of those
words because those are words that i'm
trying to learn but i think i know about
half of them so so like 24 25 000 words
in two months that's over 400 words a
day
based on being able to recognize them
uh in czech over uh one more maybe 15
month period
i have some 50 000 known words and i
created i think some 44 000 links
because i had to do more linking more
saving of words and phrases because
there were less
freebie words in check than in in
romanian so that's one extreme and i'll
get back to that extreme and of course
another person on the thread says no
to me learning a word means
learning it and slowly making sure i
know what it means and i work many
people work on flash cards and so they
deliberately learn these words make sure
they can use them and only then can they
say they know them and on that basis the
number is five words a day in french and
maybe three words and or even one word
in chinese and so forth
okay
granted there's lots of variables here
but but some of my basic principles are
that if you are focused
on being able to use the word and if you
try to deliberately learn that word so
that you can recognize it out of context
in flashcards and so that you can use it
i think you are doing yourself a great
disservice
i think that is counterproductive when
it comes to language learning and when
it comes to language acquisition
because
the time that you spend say on flash
cards scratching your brain trying to
remember what the word means to my mind
is is wasted time
you're far better off
uh to or for that matter if you are
struggling to use the few words that you
know when you're having this very
limited conversation
with someone but trying to nail down the
10 words that you learned yesterday to
me that is also counterproductive i feel
that you're much better off to be
constantly exposing yourself to more
word rich content through reading and
listening the bulk of the words that i
learn
i acquire them incidentally and so the
more words that i can recognize
the more
interesting and word rich material i can
i can read and listen to and therefore
harvest all of these free words because
as my statistics in learning romanian
and czech point out and it's the same in
other languages most of my so-called
known words are words that showed up in
our lessons that i didn't save
and so the system recognizes that these
are words that you didn't need to save
therefore you know them
and most of those therefore the biggest
growth in my vocabulary was from words
that i picked up incidentally
and so the more words that i can
recognize
the sooner i can move into
interesting content whether it be
history in my case or literature or or
for other people it might be sports or
whatever it is
so trying to limit yourself
to to sort of nailing down
uh you know
bits of vocabulary that you struggle to
study off lists and in flashcards and
anki and and you want to make sure you
can use them and stuff like that to me
is is on that basis you will learn very
few words and when it comes to this
whole passive vocabulary active
vocabulary dichotomy
in my view
when you have an opportunity to speak
more or you have the need to speak more
then a lot of this passive vocabulary
will become active
sometimes you'll remember this word and
the next time you won't but they're all
sitting there in your brain and as you
struggle to speak
in meaningful situations
then you will find yourself reaching
back there for these words especially if
again as we do on link if when you are
reading you are noticing words like when
i read and i see a handy phrase that i
want to be able to use i save it that
means it will be shown it will show up
again highlighted in yellow any time
that word or phrase appears in any
future lesson that i either find on the
link library or bring in from the
internet and so i'm training myself to
notice
and as i train myself to notice these
words and i see them again and again
slowly they become a part of my active
vocabulary but i don't focus on trying
to develop my active vocabulary and i
think that that is a better strategy for
people who live or who study
and live in places where the language
isn't spoken it's far easier to expose
yourself to this
rich
content
rather than trying to deliberately nail
down
words now
a couple of comments here it's important
that i think in my opinion it's
important that what you're listening to
and reading
is interesting has a sort of resonance
with you you like it
and that's true in all language learning
one of the comments or a couple of the
comments to my previous video where i
said one of the problems people have in
language learning is they haven't done
it before
and once they've done it once or twice
they feel confident a number of people
said well i learned english in german
but i'm having real trouble with french
and then i went back to that person and
it turns out that this person feels less
attraction to french culture than he
felt towards english or german culture
well certainly if you don't feel an
attraction to
the language to the content you're
studying all of this makes the learning
less effective so it is important
to use material that has resonance with
you so
on the subject of how many words you can
learn and how to go about learning it
and so forth and so on
yes it depends on how similar the
languages are obviously romanian was
very easy for me
and i there i was i don't know 400 words
a day
it would be the count check was more
difficult so it's 200 words a day check
has a lot of
declensions and things so that if you
try to equate that to english maybe it's
only
i don't know 70 words a day i don't know
it's a large number if you do it in my
opinion the way i do like on link i link
furiously i create as i say in romanian
in two months over 10 000 links that's
over 10 000 words that i have
deliberately saved and that appear
highlighted in yellow every time i read
and by exposing myself to a lot of
content listening and reading i've been
sort of washing all these words over me
and a lot of them are
retained
without me having to make any special
effort and so i can simply engage in
this enjoyable activity of reading and
listening to things that interest me and
the words just accumulate which is kind
of the way kids learn kids don't do
flash cards so enough now i see i've
kind of spoken quite a bit on this
i know this is a bit of a controversial
issue let me see on my notes if i forgot
anything
uh
blah blah blah no all right
um yeah look forward to your comments
and uh i'm gonna see if i can't sneak a
portuguese video in uh towards the end
of the week thank you very much bye for
now